so we've talked about a lot of different
things here with dice
let me kind of take you to a different
place you know i'll go to dinner with
friends and we'll sit there and we'll
talk
and they'll say i follow this diet i
follow that that
and then and then the the wives will
typically start with
what we all ought to do and then the
guys will gladly
debate any topic just to debate because
we have nothing better to do than debate
and see who's right and who's wrong
and then you kind of see well no that's
not how i do it you first have to do the
right twenty first get the blood
and then after you take your blood and
then when the blood that's gonna tell
you what kind of food you should eat
because it's different for a and o and b
and c and d and all this technical
something i'm just sitting there saying
oh this is so complex
and then you look at families and tell
me tell me what you've seen here with 20
000 people that have come to you
you know most people take up the
religion that their parents had if your
parents are jewish you're probably
jewish if your parents are christian or
christian
if your parents are republican you'll
typically end up being a republic
they're democrats you'll be democrat
every once in a while
you'll see somebody says you know what i
don't know if i believe in
the person you believe in i'm going to
go do my own research and then i become
something else
i don't know if i believe in being a
democrat i want to be a republican i
want to be a democrat or whatever maybe
right
but do you see a similar trend with that
being
with how we eat based on how our parents
ate
and how often you see that cycle being
broken and what causes for that to
happen
yeah it's worse than that it's not only
the you know what we've been taught
but there it you know diet is a hugely
important cultural
uh phenomena and so if you decide to
step outside the norm on diet
it's very disturbing to people you know
many of them are well-intentioned
misguided people that are genuinely
concerned for your well-being they think
if you don't adopt
uh the diet that they adopted you're
gonna be
you know it'll compromise your health
and and traditions you know i had
that experience myself you know when i
adopted this at 16 my mother was very
concerned
i had adopted this you know whole plant
food diet and my uncle who was a
physician
actually was invited over i remember
because it was my 16th birthday and
she wanted him to talk some sense into
me and he said
oh you know don't worry phil these kids
go through various diet fads and stuff
and as long as he eats plenty of gefilte
fish and you know he'll be fine
and i explained to my uncle i said no
uncle it's called being a vegan and you
know no
animal foods at all he said it's called
being a meshuggah you'll stop it right
this minute
anyway it's also i decided that that i
decided at that point what career i
wanted to pursue i wanted to get into
this alternative medicine so i told the
family i decided on my career choice
and he was really upset he was screaming
and yelling i thought i was going to
witness my first stroke
he said nobody in this family would go
to that kind of a doctor let alone
become that kind of a doctor he says
better you should be a communist spy
and he's screaming and yelling and
finally they get rid of me goes away my
dad who's a really serious guy takes me
aside he says son
i don't know anything about this
alternative medicine business he says
but anything that makes him that angry
and mad
it can't be bad so you stick to your
guns and good luck to you
my father later when i was in school i
was just coming out of school
began to have transient attacks he had
lived a conventional diet you know the
traditional
foods was having essentially mini
strokes
had lost his cognitive capacity where he
couldn't remember his grandkids names he
had to retire from teaching he was a
mess
comes into the center we just started up
undergoes 26 days of fasting recovers
his help to make a long story short 20
years later
he helped edit the pleasure trap because
he had made such a fabulous recovery so
he
ended up being a really fabulous outcome
in terms of you know doing much much
better as a consequence of dietary
change and remained
compliant interestingly enough my uncle
who uh when i'm in school and we're
doing this original work on blood
pressure
i'm trying to get him interested in
looking at our our data he won't look at
our data
i said his uncle there's a blood
pressure they're getting what he says
they're not getting well
i said they're getting well he says no
they're not getting well so i've been in
practice 50 years they never get well
they said no they're getting well he
says you don't know how to take blood
pressure okay
so anyway he says he won't look at our
data until it's published in a
peer-reviewed journal
two months before our article finally
comes out we get it accepted for
publication two months before
he dies of a massive heart attack come
on my mother swore to the day she died
he died just so he wouldn't have to
admit
he was wrong i think it was the kugel
the crep left the knishes
you know but who knows did he die april
of 01 what month did he die
because the paper is a june of o-1 right
when he came is that is that the time
wow unbelievable he never did
he never did review the data because you
know i'm sure he didn't i mean they
don't have that kind of stuff up there
yeah where he went but uh so but i i
there's no question this dietary when
you step outside the dietary norm you're
going to raise
some concerns and in fact you have to be
very careful not to become a social
outcast because you're not participating
in all the traditional habits
and learn you know in our book the
pleasure trap we talk about strategies
for going along and getting along and
not
alienating people and not shoving your
belief systems down their throat but
you know accepting uh things as they are
and hopefully they respect you enough
that they're willing to allow you
the indulgence of adopting a
health-promoting diet and lifestyle
[Music]